a quiet corner of Baden Retton back in
southern Germany but appearances are
deceiving the state is an important
center of German industry baden button
buck has more global market leaders than
any other German state mid-sized
companies based here sell their products
all over the world see you Abuk for
example specializes in ventilator units
they're exported to all corners of the
planet including to the US where they
can be found installed in structures
from residential buildings to data
centers what will happen if Donald Trump
makes good on his protectionist campaign
rhetoric
how will that affect German exports to
the US CEO Peter Franco is concerned the
protectionism that mr. Trump has
promised would of course have a
significant impact on economic activity
and presumably also on our business
relationship with the US we assume that
the punitive tariffs wouldn't apply only
to Mexico and China but would also
eventually affect the European markets
and our activities in North America the
ventilator blades incorporate elements
based on the wings of an owl the
serrated edges reduce air resistance and
allow the units to operate more quietly
more than two thirds of them go to the
US each unit is more than a meter in
diameter and is cast out of aluminum
it's a complex manufacturing process
we developed and implemented the process
over years in collaboration with our
suppliers seal avec also has a plant in
the US but that facility isn't able to
produce all of the different necessary
components many still have to be
imported from Germany punitive tariffs
would make those parts more expensive
but the company's CEO believes that any
protectionist barriers would eventually
backfire against the US
the problema team handsome the issue
with mr. Trump is that it's hard to know
exactly what his intentions are but
protectionism or typing borders for
instituting higher protective tariffs
that serves only to create a kind of
comfort zone for your own economy then
your companies no longer have to work as
hard to be competitive on the global
market over the mid or long term that
tends to significantly weaken the
economy this has been demonstrated many
times throughout history protectionism
is only useful as a short-term
instrument to win over potential voters
vanish them in the guys tongue it's
still uncertain what trade strategy
Donald Trump will actually pursue for
German companies that market to the US
long term planning has now become more
difficult Horschel is another company
based in Baden Wurttemberg that exports
around the world their products include
artificial leathers used in the
automotive industry
this cream-colored artificial leather
for example is used by Mercedes founded
more than a hundred years ago today
honcho is the global market leader in
artificial leather film and Kotick
textile production a quarter of its
profits come from the u.s. CEO hans
english Klose
is taking a wait-and-see approach
Germany benefits from global free trade
Germany has always sought to remain
competitive within a system with few
barriers that's definitely the better
course over the long term for the moment
it's impossible to say whether we'll be
dealing with protectionist tendencies or
whether actual protectionist policies
will be implemented in this move this
terrific movement on it up to zine
Han chul also has a production facility
in the US the company invested 40
million euros to build it and created
jobs but activities at the u.s. facility
don't require the same level of
technological expertise for example this
durable plastic foil used in automotive
manufacturing can't be produced there
the world is interconnected and that
won't change anytime soon
some industries are meanwhile
concentrated in specific regions given
the huge sums that have been invested in
those industries moving them elsewhere
would be difficult under the UN Fellig
and list
Donald Trump has injected a new note of
unpredictability into the global economy
and German companies will also feel the
impact